what up space fam goals in here from
anime outpour back at it again to
discuss another demonstrator character
and this time we are going over a
character that's very interesting and
possibly more hateable than doma himself
so make sure to stay tuned for this one
if you do enjoy these demonstrator
videos and want to keep them coming you
know what to do channel the slayer with
it and smash that like button with no
mercy remember smashing is strongest
demonstrator energy and passing is
scared moves on energy so choose wisely
if you haven't make this the video
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future demonstrator videos and
updates including updates about the
exciting upcoming seasons and now
without further ado let's jump into its
spoilers and all so kagaku's story
starts before he was competing with
sanitsu over who will inherit the
thunder aka rumble hashra position and
yes in one of the extra pages it is
explained that the thunder breathing
kashida is officially called the rumble
hashira but i'll often use thunder
instead so people actually know what i'm
talking about and to limit confusion
kaigaku and you might miss this on the
first read-through is actually the
little kid who betrayed stone hashirag
gyome and the children he was taken care
of in his backstory as another extra
page in the 17th volume of the manga
tells us kaigaku is the boy who invited
the demon who attacked himejima's temple
the other children had discovered that
he stole money from the temple so they
confronted him and drove him outside
that night himajima's blindness is one
reason he never knew kaigaku was missing
until the attacking demon mentioned it
another reason is that other children
lied and said kagaku was sleeping end
quote so gyome's whole tragic origin
story where he lost most of the orphans
he was taken care of and then got blamed
for their deaths too is directly related
to kaigaku who betrayed all of them to
keep his own life as we'll see making
deals with demons to get his own life
spared even at the cost of other
people's lives is an ongoing pattern in
kaigaku's life we see a flash of kaigaku
during chapter 34 when zeitu is
remembering his own training dates by
now he's went from being that demon
dealing kid to being zaitsu's thunder
breathing senpai not surprisingly this
self-centered dude was mean to zanetsu
he told him to get lost called him a
loser asked him if he's embarrassed to
be crying from dawn to dusk kagaku
clearly spoke to zenitsu as if zainto
was beneath him and by all accounts he
was skill-wise after all kaigaku knew
all the thunder-breathing forms except
the first one while zanitsu only knew
the first one to be fair kaigaku did get
ridiculed for not knowing the first one
since it is foundational but it was
probably symbolic for sensei aka gramps
aka former hashiraj jigoro of how
kaigaku and zhanitsu could make up for
each other's weaknesses and share the
title of the thunder hashira kagaku
though felt like he was superior and he
was there longer than zainitsu was so he
felt jealous and ironically he felt
betrayed that he was no longer the only
special person to jigoro and i say
ironic because he's obviously the real
traitor but moving on during the hashira
training arc zenitsu gets a letter
letting him know that his thunder gramps
has taken his own life because a thunder
breather he trained namely kaigaku
turned into a demon willingly this
changes anitsu's usually comedic manner
and he becomes uncharacteristically
serious he's so serious because of
course the loss of his gramps devastated
him but also because he is solely
focused on getting revenge on kaigaku
for what he did to the man who was like
a father figure to both of them yeah
zaitsu usually calls him gramps but
zeitsu was an orphan and jigoro was the
closest thing he ever had to a father as
well thus kaigaku wasn't just like a
senpai to him but like a brother at that
point in his life jigoro and kaigaku
were the only special people in zainzu's
life and now he has to kill one for
embracing the dark side and leading to
the death of the other best case
scenario even if he wins he's lost
everyone that used to be important to
him in that period of his life and of
course that's no laughing matter this
seriousness carries over to when zaintsu
finally confronts upper moon 6 kaigaku
during the infinity castle arc now
kaigaku used to be stronger than zenitsu
zanitsu even spoke about how he looked
up to kaigaku and was inspired by his
senpai's example and now this superior
fighter not only has demon enhancements
but upper moon demon enhancements he's
so strong that muzon let him fill dakian
yutaro's old position and remember the
only other slayer who soloed an upper
moon before besides yorichi of course
was muichiro who is considered to be one
of the most talented hashira so clearly
it looks like zaitsu is outmatched from
the get-go still zainitsu is not afraid
it's almost like he's too mad to be
afraid and unlike usual he stays
conscious throughout the fight after
zainsu orders him to come out kaigaku
says that's no way to speak to your
senior then he appears saying that
zainsoo is still shabby and zenitsu says
now that he's a demon zainsu no longer
thinks of kagaku as his senior and you
could substitute the word senpai or
brother here as well kagaku keeps
insulting zhanitsu like in the old days
calling him little runt and saying he's
still weak and patronizingly wondering
if xaito can use anything besides the
first form zlata has grown though and
can now fire back he's not the crybaby
he used to be and he tells kaigaku that
the demon seems pretty thrilled to have
reached the very bottom ranks through
merely filling in blank positions and
that's a good observation to note when
considering how strong kagaku is is he
actually strong enough to be an upper
moon or was he just put in there because
muzon wanted to fill the position well i
think zaitsu is doing a great job trash
talking but at the same time i think
kaigaku is strong enough to be upper
moon 6. they didn't need to fill every
position they didn't even fill upper
moon 5 which you know muzon could have
done if he just wanted to fill positions
so i think that yeah kaigaku deserves
the spot and in turn zainsu deserves the
credit for fighting a muzon approved
official upper moon zaitsu confronts
kaigaku about gramps's painful death but
kaigaku says he doesn't care he doesn't
care about anyone who doesn't value him
and why did he think gramps didn't value
him simply because he wouldn't make
haigaku jigoro's sole successor he
wanted to make kaigaku and zeitsu joint
successors aka joined thunder hashira
and kaigaku hated the idea thinking he
was so much above zenitsu self-centered
greed
arrogance is definitely kaigaku's
biggest vice for most people they would
have been thrilled to be a hashira who
cares if you shared a title with someone
else but kaigaku needed more he needed
all the recognition all the power he
could grab and that's why he became a
demon after kagaku again emphasizes that
zainsoo shouldn't lump them together the
fight gets started kaigaku's abilities
are very impressive if you didn't know
this yet it's important to note that
demonstrators don't actually produce or
summon their breathing element so when
you're seeing lightning in the series or
flames from tundra's dance and fire god
they are not actually real the elements
are there to emphasize how much the
sword swings actually look like their
elements and let's just say it to make
everything more hype and they succeed in
doing that however that's what makes
demon breath style users like higaku so
fascinating they can use their blood
demon art to actually produce the
elements in question making whatever
breathing style they used to use
way more deadly in kaigaku's case his
attacks actually produce lightning and
they made it black lightning which is a
really cool choice probably too cool for
a character like haigaku kaigaku's first
attack is thunder breathing fourth form
distant thunder the attack sends out
lightning in all directions and as the
name suggests it overcomes a common flaw
with swordsmanship and allows kagaku to
launch deadly long-range attacks zaini 2
though is even more amazing with his
speed and ends up cutting kagaku's neck
before the new upper moon even knew what
hit him zenith calls him too slow and
kaigaku can't help but think that
zenitsu is very fast and like a
completely different person when
compared to the one he used to know
kagakuku is not done yet though since
zenitsu didn't actually take his head
off completely we get a flashback of
when kokushibo was giving kaigaku the
blood to become a demon and it's
revealed that to turn someone who can
use breathing techniques into a demon
they must receive a great deal of blood
from muzon thus since more muzon blood
usually equals a stronger demon it's
implied that breath style users like
higaku have the potential to become
especially strong demons keep in mind
during this fight against zaitsu as will
be brought up later kaigaku is a very
new demon and chances are he would move
up the upper moon ranks if he had more
time to gain more strength and master
his powers back to the fight enkaigaku
is angry at zhenitsu's strength speed
and patronizing tone he's trying to
convince himself that zainto is weak and
worthless but he's clearly shook
nevertheless he attacks with thunder
breathing second form rice spirit as
usual this attack gives off black
lightning but it also includes five
successive attacks in one breath and in
the blink of an eye this attack does cut
zainsu's flash and zeitsu can't help but
notice that kaigaku has eaten so many
people already and as we know usually
the more people you eat as a demon the
stronger you're supposed to get kaigaku
then launches third form thunder swarm
which includes him quickly appearing
from different directions and attacking
over and over again as if there were a
swarm of him and not just one from the
outside zainsu looks like he's in the
center trapped by waves of black
lightning that surround him in all
directions this attack cuts down to
splash even more and in multiple places
they're not deadly deep wounds on their
own but as we'll see even one cut from
kaigaku could be the beginning of the
end for a human opponent kagaku then
launches fifth form heath lightning
another long range attack that hits the
target with a concentrated bolt of black
lightning once it hits it moves to
surround the whole body of the opponent
with hot black lightning while zeitu is
on the defensive kaigaku asks him how's
the sharpness of my blade infused with
blood demon art an attack that slashes
and burns the flesh he goes on to use
thunder breathing sixth form rumble and
flash this attack gets almost an entire
two-page spread so you can assume it's
the strongest of kagaku's attacks again
it appears to launch long-range black
lightning attacks but this time the
lightning slashes like a sword and
zainitsu is hit in multiple places at
the same time at least six places by my
account kaigaku explains that any
slashing attack 72 takes will continue
to rend aka tear apart his flesh kagaku
says and i quote my power burns into
your eyes and body i became a demon and
surpassed thunder breathing end quote
and in a sense he really did he didn't
surpass it in the sense that he could
beat any thunder breather but he did
surpass the limitation of not actually
being able to produce lightning it's
undeniable that this ability to produce
lightning comes in handy in combat
especially when you consider as he said
the attacks continued to spread like
poison in the body tearing apart more
and more flesh pretty soon the slashes
on zaisu's face will spread to his eyes
and then he'd lose his vision and that
they could spread to his brain and you
could see how very quickly this battle
could be over it's one of the deadliest
blood demon arts we've seen however
kaigaku still isn't as special as he
thinks he is and zains was remembering
his gramps telling him to be more like
his big brother kaigaku he also
remembers some kids making fun of kagaku
for not being able to learn the
foundational first form zlatan defended
his big bro and instead of being
flattered kaigaku berated him saying and
i quote i heard you hit a higher ranking
guy don't cause problems it's
embarrassing you're even here end quote
even if they sort of hated each other
zain to respect the kagaku from the
bottom of his heart because he worked so
hard and he was always ahead of zenitsu
saints was always looking at his back to
use his own words zaitsu says gramps and
kaigaku were special and important
people to him but for kagaku that wasn't
enough he was never satisfied and so he
went down the wrong path because he
never put a stop to his greedy desires
this is when zaintsu overcomes their old
connection once and for all he
apologized to his gramps and to kagaku
and unleashes the epic zaitsu created
seventh form of thunder breathing
flaming thunder god or honoy kaizuchi
nokami the attack finishes kaigaku off
no problem furthermore it was so fast
kagaku a demon enhanced thunderbreather
couldn't even see it ironically zenitsu
created that form because he wanted to
be able to fight with kagaku as an equal
but he actually ended up surpassing him
with it it's funny how the guy who just
wanted to be equal became stronger and
the guy who always thought he was
stronger turned out to be weaker it
really goes to show the importance of
doing your best without being arrogant
and greedy i've said this before it's
likely that zenith could have unleashed
this attack sooner and finished off
kaigaku but i think he was also trying
to work through the idea of taking the
life of his brother and it took him some
time to build up enough conviction to do
it that is likely in my view but it is
an assumption not a fact and since we
are trying to make a case for kagaku
strength since this video is focused on
kaigaku let's just look at the outcome
for a second while kaigaku is dying he
feels relieved that at least zenitsu
will lose too it's not his loss it's
more like a tie kagaku thinks since an
exhaust designs was falling to his doom
as well ironically at this point the guy
who always thought he was better is
trying to make himself feel better by
saying it was a tie but then yushiro
comes in and saves anitsu showing how
important making connections and being
nice to people is so if we strictly look
at the outcome and what happened it
actually would have been a tie if it was
a pure one-on-one battle in the sense
that zanitsu would have lost his life
too even if he somehow survived the fall
the black lightning would have continued
to tear apart his flesh until it
destroyed him luckily though yoshiro
also had an agent that stops the advance
of blood demon arts developed by tamayo
so they were able to stop the
destruction of zaitsu's flesh after the
fight yushiro goes on to tell zainto
that the upper moon he was fighting
still hadn't mastered his techniques and
abilities which is lucky he says if the
fight had been one year later kaigaku
probably would have killed zenitsu
immediately this shows how much
potential kagaku had a part of me since
i love zhanitsu thinks that zenith would
have gotten a lot stronger in a year too
so maybe it doesn't matter but we're
focusing on kaigaku in this video and so
we should fully consider the
implications of yushu's words here thus
in kaigaku we have a dude who was
considered to be better at thunder
breathing than zanitsu when they were
training under gramps he then became a
demon so strong that muzon approved of
him being upper moon 6. he developed
cool and op black lightning powers that
greatly enhanced the power speed and
deadliness of his thunder breeding forms
and finally he unexperienced as he was
arguably got a tie in a one-on-one fight
to the death against zenitsu who had to
create a brand new breathing form i'd
argue the strongest of all forms to take
his life following the fight you should
have felt like hagaku probably would
have won instantly if he had another
year to actually master his demon
techniques and abilities so those are
the facts i do personally think zainsu
should be considered stronger than
kaigaku but i also think zainito is
arguably the strongest thunder breather
in history after the creation of the
seventh form so that doesn't make
haigaku weak and once we take yushiro's
words about kaigaku's inexperience into
account it's easy to assume that kaigaku
could have become a real monster given
enough time i think he definitely
deserved the upper moon 6 spot and given
the hype the story places around the
breath style using demons it's easy to
picture him moving up the ranks i can
personally easily see him surpassing the
old upper moon 5 in power the one that
muichiro beat if he were given enough
time to he clearly wasn't there yet
though or muzon would have just gave him
the empty upper moon 5 position rather
than specifically placing him in the
number 6 position but that is it for
kaigaku one of the most hateable
characters i'd argue even more hateable
than doma but he managed to get his
hands on one of the coolest powers a
black lightning demon art that epically
enhanced his thunder breathing forms
both of these factors made his fight
with zenitsu one of the most satisfying
fights in the entire series if not the
most satisfying one if you did enjoy
this video and want to keep the
demonstrator videos coming you know what
to do channel the slayer within and
smash that like button with no mercy
remember smashing is strong as
demonstrate energy and passing is scared
moose on energy so choose wisely if you
haven't make this the video subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications or you will miss
future demonstra videos and updates
including updates about the exciting
upcoming seasons and while you wait for
the next video to drop feel free to
check out my huge and growing
demonstrator playlist that includes
videos on all the demon moons all
hashira and much more link to that is in
the description and until next time see
ya space cowboys